Magnus could anything change your mind
to play in the world championship if the
format changes
I think specifically the games would
have to be shorter let me preface this
by saying that I'm not intending to put
any pressure whatsoever on
feeder or trying to change the formats
this is just my
my thoughts and my opinion uh the one
non-negotiable point for me if I ever
were to to play the world championship
again is that
there would have to be more games and
shorter time controls
and
I I think specifically two games in a
day is
um
it's very very interesting and then time
control could be uh for instance in our
per player and then some some increment
at some points
so
with the classical time control I think
there is
there is just no way that I'm returning
to the world championship